مره اخرى اذهب الى ضيف ساعات السفير جيمس
دوبلز واسال عن كنا نتحدث قبل الفاصل عن
الصين الان باختصار الى اين يمكن ان تتجه
الاوضاع مع الصين على مستوى الاوروبي وعلى
مستوى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعتقد بان الاجابه عن هذا السؤال صعب جدا
فليس واضحا
الى اين يتجه الرئيس شيا فيما يخص
دفعه
صعود الصين او الى ماذا اي مدى يرغب
بالوصول اليه
فقد
تنعى عن سياساتي اسلافه
والتي تمثلت بتجنب النزاعات والتركيز على
النمو الاقتصادي وهذا الرئيس الصيني اقصد
شي لا يتجنب النزاعات والمواجهات على
الاقل الكلاميه
وكما ان نسب النمو قد تضاعفت
يواجه اوضاع عنه حيث الشعبيته بدات
بالانخفاض وبشكل سريع
والاقتصاده لن ينمو بنفس السرعه التي نما
عليها خلال عشرين عاما الماضيه
سلوكياته في نفس الوقت والسلوكيات الصين
بشكل عام توحد الدول ضده
فهل سيستمر في هذا الطريق ام
[موسيقى]
حل السياره اي مصلحه في
الضغط مثلا على اعاده التوحيدي تايوان او
ضميه ام هل سيعودون الى سياسات
الرؤساء السابقين للصين الذين مثلوا
تحديات اقل العالم وهذا ما ادار بفائده
كبيره للصين على الاقل وعلى الصعيد
الاقتصادي لا اعرف الاجابه عن هذه الاسئله
ولكن اعرفه بان سياسته
موجهه تجاه التشجيع على ذلك
وبالتاكيد هنالك ايضا مستوى من او البعض
قلقون اكثر مني فيما يخص الصين
يعني على المستوى الاقتصادي لا يوجد حتى
الان ما يشير الى انه الاقتصاد الصيني
سيتراجع قريبا وهنا نتساءل دائما عن رؤيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي لهذه المساله المهمه جدا عن صيد
العالم